etwas gedacht und herzlich willkommen zu
einem video ich hoffe natürlich euch
jetzt ich habe vor einiger zeit mal die
seite zoll auktion.de entdeckt wie dann
haben wir schon sagt dort wird ware vom
zoll versteigert früher gab es noch in
fast allen großen städten so live zur
aktion wo man hingehen konnte aber das
meiste wird durchs internet ist halt
einfach online versteigert da gibt es
wirklich alles mögliche von autos über
computer handys irgendwelche luxus
artikel was weißt ich fand das recht
interessant und ich denke da lohnt es
sich mal ein video darüber zu machen
deswegen habe ich mich vor einem herr
wochen mal hingesetzt um da ein paar
sachen zu ersteigern leider muss ich
sagen dass mein erster eindruck jetzt
nicht so gut war dass man da wirklich
sachen richtig günstig bekommt die man
dann teurer weiterverkaufen kann aber
ich habe einiges versteigert das ganze
habe ich auf meinem anderen kanal alexa
ist ja einfach nur mitgefilmt also
checkt das video gerne noch ab aber
sonst hier die highlight und auch was
ich jetzt im nachhinein noch ersteigert
habe ich habe heute mittag einfach mal
155 euro aufgeboten und wenn ich die 450
euro bekommen sollte dann wäre das an
sich ganz in ordnung soll option ds eine
im internet betrieben aktionsplattform
der bundeszollverwaltung über diese
plattform für das hauptzollamt gießen
permanente öffentliche bestellung durch
man es hat mich irgendwann verboten muss
sich 165 euro bezahlen also wirklich
wenn da jetzt noch eine weiter mit
bietet dann lohnt sich das schon fast
gar nicht mehr egal ich will dir einfach
haben ich will auch mal sehen was kommt
da an und so ist auch egal wenn ich da
jetzt zu viel geld bezahlt
die option ist verändert dann habe ich
das doch jetzt bekommen oder gewonnene
auktionen leute sieht man hier für 155
euro sogar schauen wir mal was ist hier
noch zu gibt und wo ich noch drauf
bieten kann genau haben hier tatsächlich
gerade und irgendeinem es kann gut sein
das ist die rolex von irgendeinem klaren
boss aus deutschland nicht das alter so
eine leistung wenn wir zu grün die feier
ich hab' ich finde die eagles sexy die
uhr eine original box und original
papiere dabei das ist schon mal du aber
hier war gerade marc gebauer der verkauf
hier so ein ähnliches modell für 30 oder
guck mal also wenn ich dir jetzt hier
für 17 bekommen sollte dann wäre das gut
aber das ist mir ein bisschen zu
riskieren keine ahnung ich kann ja nicht
einfach irgendwas bieten was ich noch
nie in der hand hatte und dann direkt so
viel das würde ich niemals machen aber
interessant das ist ja sowas gibt hier
könnte ich jetzt wenn ich den für für
den preis bekomme jetzt in dem fall 62
euro wenig glück gehabt dass verdoppeln
aber ist halt die frage ob das wirklich
klappt so ja leute ich habe jetzt einige
gebote abgegeben ich bin einfach mal
gespannt
leute was geht ich bin hier gerade auf
einer play sie dabei die liegt bei 140
ps slim mit controller und mein
höchstgebot ich hoffe das ist jetzt
sofort vorbei also dass wir auf jeden
fall sehr sehr wichtig weil place sind
gefragt wo man ist hoffe ich dass let's
go alter playstation 4 440 euro also da
werde ich auf jeden fall mit controller
oder werde ich auf jeden fall gewinnen
machen
war diese aktion übrigens noch vorbei
von dem computer ich habe weiß ich gar
nicht mehr genau was ich mit gefilmt
habe dann hab ich jetzt bekommen ihre 82
euro und die dinger werden im internet
zwischen 120 und 140 euro gehandelt also
ich glaube das war in ordnung wobei ich
habe gesehen es wurden auch noch glaube
ich zehn stück von den dingern für
insgesamt 430 euro ist brands solch ein
ich hab ein screenshot gemacht
versteigert also dann ca 40 euro pro
computer aber die musste erst mal alle
loswerden will noch nicht zu viel sagen
keine ahnung ob das gut wird übrigens
leute ist das hier das video was bereits
auf einem anderen kanal kamen ich
versuche playstation günstig beim zu
ersteigern wo ganz viele sherlock in den
kommentaren geschrieben haben das jahr
150 euro viel zu viel wirst du niemals
wieder rausbekommen hier zum beispiel
was du da ersteigert hat es eine ps4
slim und die bekommt man schon bei ebay
kleinanzeigen für 80 bis 120 euro also
keine ahnung aber ich bin mir eigentlich
sicher dass hier für mehr geld verkauft
genau geworden sind jetzt zwei ps4 und
auch so ein computer würde sagen das
reicht eigentlich erstmal zum anfang und
wir schauen mal was man damit so
anfangen kann wir haben gerade montag
und ein paket es so angekommen ich kann
es euch gerne zeigen wurden jetzt hierzu
geschickt vom finanzamt dresden hat mit
den habe ich auch telefoniert ich habe
das mit gefühlen weil ich habe keinen
plan wie das eigentlich läuft nachdem
ich da was ersteigert hat jack das gern
mal kurz aus und alex haben und zwar
häufig andere tolle aktionen was
ersteigert untersteht jetzt ihr kontakt
als ansprechpartner und ich wollte mal
ganz kurz waren in welcher weise machen
wollte und ist aber gerne zugeschickt
bekommen möchte weil da müsste ich ja
noch ein bisschen für versand
draufzahlen
ja und überweisen die anstatt
jahrhundert mit ihren konten überweisen
178 dieser summe gehen wird verwarnt
das soll nun für zu esprimo einen
computer so schön die beiden männer
partner sofort nach plan
[Musik]
und die adresse nehmen sie dann von
meinem account einfach
super stehen dann auf wiedersehen
chelsea
und hier ist glaube ich der computer
drin mit 82 euro habe ich denn hier
bekommen und die woche kommen jetzt noch
die beiden ps hier an und dann packen
wir das alles zusammen mal aus wenn
alles da ist und versuchen das dann mit
möglichst viel gewinn weiterzuverkaufen
umzuschauen kann man mit voll option
geldverdienen bin gespannt ein bisschen
mit der sicherlich drin sein egal ist es
soweit was geht ab alles fleisch so
haben wir drei pakete die sind jetzt
endlich auch mal angekommen hier haben
wir einmal den computer damit starte ich
einfach mal so viel dazu sagen kann ich
jetzt eigentlich noch nicht sagen wir
machen jetzt einmal alles aufbauen was
der zoll da so zusammengepackt hat eine
hier war das ja das finanzamt oder hat
jemand seine steuern nicht bezahlt und
zack kommt der gerichtsvollzieher vorbei
und die playstation 4 1 in richtiger
typischer gamer weitermacht ist meine an
so haben wir einmal die rechnung
per überweisung dankeschön dann haben
wir hier zeitungen aus dresden
wahrscheinlich zeitung und hier haben
wir da ein bisschen gucken jetzt
wirklich so aus kommen wir ja der ist im
padam balletttänzerin kilogramm koks
beschlagnahmt ballon war dann noch mal
zwei pakete über drei sogar drucks mdma
und christian piero also nein ich würde
mich darüber nicht lustig ist nur spaß
und hier haben den computer irgendwie
wirklich richtig so amateurhaft mit zur
zeitung eingepackt als wenn die das
nicht also das muss man auch
professionellen machen beim zeug werden
das ja auch nicht so einmal die woche
machen wieso eine privatperson schauen
wir uns den computer mal an
hier ist gar nicht der computer drin
hier ist die playstation drin
entschuldigung ich habe übrigens für die
play sie noch zwölf euro versand bezahlt
was finde ich ein bisschen vieles für
dieses paket das kostet eigentlich nur
49 90eur gott also ich finde euch das
mal ab wo sich die aus overkill ich
hoffe dir ist nicht wirklich defekt hier
steht sondereffekt logo drauf dafür habe
ich 100 5 euro bezahlt plus 12 euro
versand also insgesamt 162 wie die muss
ich eigentlich maximal acht okay ich
dachte schon hier ist noch der
controller drin das ist das kabel ich
denk mal kurz ob die angeht
läuft leute alles gut okay also um die
jetzt weiterzuverkaufen mache ich
wahrscheinlich ist iker ab und machte
ein bisschen sauber dann läuft das schon
da ich mir auch mal allem was für einen
zustand hier der controller ist ja auch
kein guter zustand sogar einer mit kabel
8 heißt also ich glaube das war kein
guter deal vielleicht verdiene ich an
den dingen 20 euro am ende hoffen was
macht na ja ich würde sagen hier müsste
eigentlich die nächste ps4 drin sein
machen wir mal weiter damit die ist auf
jeden fall ein bisschen entspannter
verpackt einmal hier ein controller das
ist schon mal ganz gut auch nicht mehr
so der wildeste zustand aber ich habe
gehört leihstation vier controller
werden nicht mehr produziert genauso
wenig wie die ps4 was eigentlich ganz
gut ist und das treibt gerade die
marktpreise nach oben war dann jetzt
doch die ps4 die eigentlich in einem
ähnlichen schuster ist bisschen
verstaubt wie die andere da ist halt
kein sticker drauf habe also die haben
sich jetzt nicht so viel sorgen darum
gemacht ob das ding in hailer ankommt
aber naja und die haben wir jetzt noch
das letzte paket das müsste dann jetzt
der computer seien auch hier legal
einfach paket 28 kilogramm das liegt
vielleicht ist halt dann teurer checke
ich überhaupt nicht also als wären das
richtige amateure die kenne ich doch die
dinger guck mal hier mal so ein bisschen
polsterung auch was mache ich jetzt
damit muss sich jetzt einmal kurz in den
karton schütten
hat super geklappt ist keins daneben
gegangen und dann haben wir hier den
fujitsu
computer mit dem kabel ach so laut ich
muss aber sagen jeder computer der sieht
wirklich aus wie neu also wird nur ein
unterstrich aber sonst super zustand
eine hierfür
ich weiß es nicht insgesamt bezahlt habe
ich mit versand 90 euro für den computer
los
162 euro für die playstation plus 148
euro für die andere playstation haben
wir bei 400 euro also leute mein ziel
wird es sein 500 euro rauszuholen nach
versand also versand muss der käufer
bezahlen und dann finde ich das ding
gelungen ob ich das schaffe wird
schwierig aber hoffen wir mal wächst ab
der fotografie randers und versuchen es
zu verkaufen eigentlich lieber über ebay
kleinanzeigen weil da habe ich keine
gebühren vielleicht habe ich auch noch
ein kumpel der eine playstation haben
will ich weiß es nicht wir werden sehen
leute wünscht mir glück ich hab mir dann
erst mal gedacht machte die places schön
sauber schwimmend oder vor allem diese
ganzen ekligen sticker ab machst dein
geile fotos lädt sie bei ebay hoch oder
sonstwo weil ja keine ahnung wenn man
schöne fotos hat kriegt man sicherlich
auch mehr geld und wenn die dinger
halbwegs vernünftig aussehen ist es
natürlich auch ich schlecht dann hab ich
so fotografiert wenn man hier noch sehen
und ja dort einfach mal hochgeladen
so ich habe jetzt alles ins internet
gestellt den computer und eine ps4 slim
bei ebay und die andere bei
kleinanzeigen keine ahnung ich wollte
das so ein bisschen streuen ich habe
natürlich dann immer noch eine ebay
gebühr die mit abgeht aber sonst wird's
safe zu lange dauert also gerade bei dem
computer den kann ich eigentlich nur
hier verkaufen hier habe ich jetzt
einmal den computer dann habe ich für
knapp 150 reingestellt ich muss sagen da
war ich sogar überrascht weil der ist
hier nirgendwo für weniger drin schaut
mal her 185 185 das hier ist jetzt eine
versteigerung also ich glaube da werde
ich auf jeden fall 150 euro erzielen und
die ps4 habe ich hier mit 195 euro in
getan aber auch preisvorschläge ab 162
euro wären okay die andere ps4 habe ich
für 180 euro bei kleinanzeigen drin also
wenn ich das alles zu dem preis verkaufe
dann erreiche ich mein ziel schauen wir
mal ob es klappt
leute was geht ich sitze jetzt hier
macht das ende vom video eigentlich
sollte das video heute kommen wir mal
donnerstags kommt jetzt allerdings erst
morgen kann ich trotzdem den fazit zwei
sachen habe ich verkauft eine sache noch
nicht ich würde sagen starten wir
erstmal mit dem computer den habe ich
verkauft wird tatsächlich 150 euro klar
ich muss doch eine ebay gebühren das
sind ungefähr 10 prozent hatten wir
schon mal bei 135 euro - 90 habe ich ja
bezahlt wieder dinge zu gewinnen das ist
echt stark vor allem wenn ich daran
denke dass ihr auf der website 10 von
den dingern für etwas mehr als 400 euro
verkauft wurden ich habe es euch ja
eingebildet damit hätte man station
richtig richtig guten deal gemacht also
ich ärgere mich ein bisschen dass ich
die nicht erworben hat und dann habe ich
glücklicherweise ebenfalls über ebay
also nicht über ebay kleinanzeigen noch
die playstation 4 verkauft mit
controller für 180 euro ebenfalls wieder
zehn prozent abziehen dann wir hier bei
162 euro - 140 euro die ich dafür
ausgegeben habe es schon gar nicht bei
148 dafür bezahlt und versand geht zum
euro gewinn
naja haben wir hier immerhin schon 59
euro raus geholt jetzt mal optimistisch
an die sache dass sich die andere über
ebay kleinanzeigen noch loswerden da
mache ich dann ein gewinn von 20 euro
landen wir bei
79 euro insgesamt was ich dann mit der
ganzen sache verdient haben also mein
fazit an sich eine coole sache und es
lohnt sich sicherlich da auch so als
privatmensch mal reinzuschauen und
vielleicht ist da hin und wieder mal ein
guter schnapper dabei damit jetzt
wirklich viel geld zu verdienen ist ein
bisschen schwierig aber ich werde die
seite im auge behalten und vielleicht
wieder mal was gutes ersteigern um
darüber videos zu drehen wer weiß
ansonsten leute probiert hat euch
gefallen abonniert sehr sehr gern den
kanal wir sind fast wieder eine million
oder vielleicht bleiben auf dem
einwilligung ist eigentlich das
zuschauen